well as you say um first of all a lot of
activity here in Westminster today just
within the past couple of hours we've
heard from Downing Street this is a
Downing Street spokesperson who said the
Prime Minister has had a phone call with
U.S President Biden French president
macron a German chancellor Schultz they
spoke this afternoon to discuss the
situation in Russia you can see there
and reiterate their continuing support
for Ukrainian sovereignty this follows
the call between G7 foreign ministers
which the foreign secretary participated
in earlier today the leaders have agreed
to stay in close contact in the coming
days that was something that we heard
from the Prime Minister earlier today
that he would be reaching out to allies
and Confirmation just within the last
few hours that those conversations have
taken place was also earlier a meeting
convened a cobra meeting that's the
government's emergency committee so that
will include senior ministers and civil
servants other relevant people that need
to be brief during that meeting that was
chaired by the foreign secretary after
that we had a statement from the foreign
office saying the foreign secretary has
chaired a meeting of Cobra to update on
the latest situation particularly with
respect to British Nationals in Russia
and that is something as well that Rishi
sunak has been coming commenting on
clearly a priority in government here to
assess and understand the situation of
British Nationals in Russia an update
advice
um to them if necessary obviously this
is very fast-moving situation as we've
seen just in the last hour or so but in
a in an interview earlier
and he did say when he was asked about
that we've had long-standing travel
advice against travel to Russia people
and this refers to people who are
already there should keep checking the
foreign office website so I think it's
fair to say that that probably uh still
applies I think at the moment what's
quite clear is that is there is a a lot
of activity a lot of meetings going on
senior people being briefed and all of
that information uh go being passed
around in government is happening at
speed to reflect the urgency of the
situation on the ground in Russia but
the approach in terms of the public is
to keep that that level of information
to a minimum they are as many people
across the world are now watching the
situation and waiting to see what
happens in the next few hours in the
next few days